hello everyone and welcome to the most
awaited clash of the Olympiad
it's Fabian encore one of the United
States and he's facing shattered my
media reversal by John a true clash of
titans on board one two of them along
magnus carlsen are well also along ding
Lehrer Nessie is now the fourth member
of the twenty eight hundred Club so a
nice clash of twenty eight hundred and
it's the opening is completely a
theoretical struggle as you would expect
from such high rated players and we're
gonna skip the opening in its entirety
since it's been played so many times by
so many players but it will really show
you how much preparation really counts
in these high-level battles so without
further ado let's check out a couple of
photos there we have a nice photo by
David Lada as you can see everything is
in order really really enjoying the
boards there they are quite exquisite
and as you can see Carwin are still
refusing to wear his blue blazer as he
doesn't want to be mistaken for a 1950s
a hamburger joint worker and here we
have a very nice photo of mamita also by
David Lauda so having seen these let's
check out the game like we said he for
five we have Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and Bishop to b5 do real Lopez a6 rush
up to a 4 Knight to f6 and castles so
more fees defenses on the board Knight
captures on e4 d 4 and now b5 this is a
the same opening Caruana and the Mamedov
have already played but we're gonna get
back to that Bishop to b3 we have d5 and
now D captors on e5 Bishop to e6 Knight
B to d2 Knights the c5 going after the
bishop on b3 here we have C 3 and now
Bishop to e7 it's also possible to
capture the bishop on b3 but this
position was analyzed so many times that
it doesn't really do anything all that
much for black Bishop to e7 hands now
Bishop back to C to D for we had nice
the b3 and now comes even d3 so black
creates this very powerful d3 pawn and
although it seems like black is
dominating here it's actually a very
well a theoretical very well known
theoretical line that both of them have
already played Bishop to be one we have
nice capture Sun b38 capture some v3 and
the now Bishop to f5 and this is the
position that I was talking about here
Caruana already had this position on the
board against mamedyarov he had it in
st. Louis rapid event in 2018 were
corona proceeded to with pawn to b4 and
also Medea of had this position against
the Anand also in 2018 in the sinful cup
and that game was drawn but the game
were Fabiano played before that game
Fabian also won against mom they are off
so Bishop to e3 seems like a new move
but it's not that the game will actually
transpose into the exact same game and
already played against a mammoth yard so
we have castles here and this is still
completely the same rush up to d4 Queen
to d5 we have rook to e1 and now d2
still this is still considered old
standard theory rook to e2 getting the
Ricardo way now attacking the d2 pawn
and now comes the Bishop captures on b1
rook captures on b1 and now Knight
captures on d4 with a knife captures on
d4 and now comes the Bishop to g5
defending the d2 pawn and here we have
g3 this is a the first move where where
Caruana spent some time or all of the
moves up until this point were played in
a matter of seconds so the only move
where Khurana started thinking was g3
but still he only spent one minute and
49 moves on g3 okay we have c5 Knight
goes to f5 and now comes the Queen to d3
knight back to the six we have Queen to
g6 and h4 and now again we transpose
into the exact same position which one
at an island head against a Sheryl
mamedyarov
were Anand played h4 and Mama drf
continued with Bishop to h6 in the scene
filled Cup where they drew their game
and here you can see that mama DRF came
prepared to this game against Caruana
the only improved move for black is the
that is Bishop to f4 and this is in fact
with mommy DRF plays so hard to say if
this actually came as a surprise for
Caruana or not but for his next move
which is the strongest reply Khurana
plays Knight back to e4 which took in
some 10 minutes you have to be careful
if you want to play a move like King to
h2 to simply unpin and now threaten to
capture the bishop didn't Bishop
captures on e5 very simple rook captures
now the night is no longer defended the
the pawn on d2 is now defended by the
Queen rook ad it is coming and all of a
sudden black is much better here so
Knight to e4 by Caruana we have f5
kicking the knight back and now he
captures on f6 is a possibility you can
capture here but then rotate to it white
gets a lot of development for this pawn
and you can't just keep on grabbing
pawns because here black would be the
one that would be stronger and the d2
pawn cannot be captured because after
Knight captures rook captures rook Queen
captures rook and now you simply remove
the defender and you notice that the
queen is actually eyeing this rook so
after you move the rook Bishop goes back
and black black is up a piece would with
a better position
so after f5 we have knife capture some
d2 Caruana has to eliminate this very
strong passed pawn and now look a to d8
pinning the night rook to e1 getting the
rook out of the way so if the position
opens the Queen will not be attacking it
via this diagonal and also pressuring a
six here we have rook F to e8 and now
comes the Queen to e1 and now mama dog
decides to exchange we have Bishop
captures on b2 rook after Sundy to look
out for sandy - Queen captures and d2
and the now comes row captors on e5
Queen to d8 check
rook defense would an attack on the
Queen Queen to d5 check with your queen
to e6 and now rook to d1 and here the
material on the board is completely
equal a madea respond structure is even
somewhat better as whites be pawns or
double but it's not really all that
important as
mamuro's rook will not have the
opportunity to attack the B to pawn
where is the a6 pawn is somewhat
vulnerable so it's it's in fact white
who is better here and here if you
decide to capture here sure this is
possible after Luke captures now the C
pawn and the F pawn or under attack
but now rook to e2 is a very strong move
and now after captures and capture some
B to the beat three pawn is under attack
and after you defended black defends the
FI pawn and now it's a a pretty drawn
and game but Mamedov doesn't go for this
in fact he could have also gone for f4
simply deciding to trade it down even
further on the King side to you know
further improve the the drawing of this
game but he decides to go for c4 he goes
for some complications and okay but B
captures on c4 b Capra's on c4 and now
Queen to b7 now the Queen trade is no
longer an option for Mahmud are off and
Caruana now does seem to have the upper
hand as these pawns are somewhat weak
okay rook to e7 a madea of attack score
one as Queen we have a rope to da check
King to f7 and now Queen back to f3 and
now it doesn't really matter what the
engine evaluation is you can see that
the King on f7 the rope cutting of the
King it's not not a very pleasant
position for for black to be in here g6
has played something like rook to e8
it's pretty much all the same after
after something like rook to d5 with a
double attack against this pawn g6 would
have still been played so why not to do
it immediately we have g6 and now comes
Queen to f4 and here Queen to c6 a very
nice move by Mahmud yeah if you try
something like Queen to e1 check and
then go for some mating ideas here or or
try to win the Queen it's actually black
wood yet checkmate it after Queen
captures on c4 you can't find safety
anywhere for example in age sex because
rook to g8 check King h6 and now Queen
to f4 will lead to checkmate after Queen
g5 so after Queen to f4 Queen to c6 and
here we have rook to d1 getting
you have to protect the first rank if
you try something else instead of this
rook to d1 move for example if you try
something like rook to d6 then you would
get checkmated after rook to e1 King
moves and not rook to h1 is checkmate as
the Queen from c6 is so conveniently
covering the h1 square okay after Queen
to c6 rook to d1 Caruana has to bring
the rook back and here we have rook to
e4 attacking the Queen Queen to h6 now
attacking the h7 pawn King goes back to
g8 and now you don't really gain
anything by rook b8 black simply brings
his own route back rook to e8 so we have
h5 here Corona wants to break open the
King's defenses rook back to e8 we'll
have phone captures pawn captures and
now King to f1 a very nice move because
now karana can activate his rook as
there are no more rook to e1 ideas the
king is now guarding d1 square
rook to e6 with a further protection of
the g6 pawn and now we have Queen to h4
a very nice very nice geometry by white
here guarding the da square hoping that
this rook will come to d8 so rook to e8
simply not allowing this but now comes
Rock to d4 and now this comes with a
double attack against the c4 pawn and
here it's very difficult to find an
actual defensive move against rook
captures on c4 and here you see what
Carlsen will face in in November to play
against Caruana he will have to find a
very nice engine line like pawn to a5
where you can see that now that now that
you know this of course after Luke
captures on c4 going to be 7 and now the
B to pawn is under attack
so black would actually be fine here
after a move like rook to c5 Queen
captures here and here it would be
actually very hard for white to get to
get out of trouble ideas like a queen to
be one to d3 are coming and the rook
will now be a very dangerous piece and
it's most likely white that will have to
go for some perpetual ideas with Queen
to c4 to d4 but okay after rook to d4
mom Jared decides to play rook to see it
now he does defender the pond but this
simply doesn't work
have Queen to h6 and what do you do now
now you see that the Queen and rook are
guarding the pawn but they are so far
away from protecting the King side and
now rook to h4 is definitely an idea
here so Queen to e6 but now comes to
Luke to h4 as planned
King to have seven momager of tries to
run away with the King Queen to h7 this
comes with check King to f6 and now rook
to d4 we have Queen to e7 deciding to
trade Queens but of course karana is not
interested in this and here you you
really see what kind of a person you are
are you a pawn grabber or are you not a
pawn grabber you can always go for
something like Queen to h4 check and
after King moves simply rook captures on
c4 grab a nice pawn and after Queen
captures rook captures and then hope you
can win a four versus three endgame
Fabiano is not a pawn grabber so instead
he goes Queen to h6 a very nice move
keeping all of his options open and
black doesn't really have a good move
here here King to f7 Mammadov didn't
really see any any ideas behind behind
Queen to h6 or perhaps he did but he's
hoping therefore Caruana to repeat moves
and perhaps to get a draw by threefold
repetition and this is I left the quote
above the board by even Sokolov it's
easy to tweet when your engine does all
the work because this is the position
even Sokolov had in mind during the live
coverage where he said like I where is
the win I don't see the win and everyone
was like yeah there's a win in the
comments and well feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this idea
everyone was tweeting about I'll give
you a couple of seconds as usual so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
follower of my all of my other social
media as like in the previous video I
have a video I have already mentioned
this and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show the idea is G for a
very poisonous move threatening to bust
open the king side here but also if
black isn't careful even g5 is an idea
for example now if you try something
like rook to e8 now you get Queen - h7
check and now King
to f6 is no longer possible because g5
check a beautiful move where now if you
capture it you get Queen to h4 checkmate
very nice idea and if you don't capture
it if you play something like King to a5
King to e5 you get Queen chapters on g6
and now there is no defense against f4
checkmate or you can prevent f4 by
pushing it for yourself but then you get
Queen to e4 checkmate
very nicely done so I was talking to f7
Caruana didn't find this tweety move and
instead he goes Queen to d2 a more
human-like idea simply preparing a rook
to d7 mama D ro defense it rocked the c7
and now we have looked to h4 again
threatening rook to h7 to simply win the
Queen and the game King to f6 Mahmud ro
tries to run away but now Queen to d4
Czech Queen to e5 blocking now comes the
Queen to b6 check King to g7 and now
Queen to b8 and how the Queen traveled
all this way to now get a get back to
the ad h-file king to have six and now
Queen to H it with check King to e6 and
now comes the Queen to g8 with check and
here you don't really have a lot of
options if you block with the rook rook
to h7 a double attack Queen to f6
blocking and now Quinta eh Czech Queen
has to block or you move the king and
then the rook is lost so Queen has the
block and now Queen the c6 check King to
e5 and now f4 will again be checkmate as
the pawn and Queen are conveniently
covering all of these squares so after a
queen to g8 check King to f6 was played
but now comes look to d4 again a very
nice move so what do you play here if
you try something like rook to e7 with
some I hopes of doing something here
along the e-file Queen to f8 is the idea
look to f7 and again Queen checks rook
the g7 and now again a double attack and
there's no way to guarded the rook so
after this rook to d4 Queen to e7 was
played and now rook to d8 there's white
is just pressuring here there's really
nothing to do and more importantly this
is moved 59 and my media of is extremely
low on time and this
move one move to the second time control
yes you have to make it to move 62 get
to be given additional time so here
would rook to d7 black could still hope
to survive a bit longer and perhaps even
survive the game but here mama D are for
his move that reaches time control plate
King to g5 and now it is all over
Fabiano played f4 with check we have
king to h5 and now my media of saw
precisely that if something like going
to H a display think the g4 comes and
now there are no more checks perhaps the
black can recover but still it would be
very hard after king to f2 as the King
doesn't really have anywhere to go
so after this King to h5 rook to d2 was
played here now
Bobby's a threatening rook to h2 and
there really isn't anything to do here
anymore
Queen to g7 was played if you try
something like King the g4 immediately
again
Queen Queen to g6 is now coming as the
Queen is now not on h8 so after up to d2
went to g7 offering a queen trade but
now a Fabi ends the game in great style
we have root 2 H to check King goes to
g4 and now we have King to g2 a very
nice simple Queen sacrifice to enter the
game idea is of course if the Queen if
the queen is captured sorry if the queen
is captured then rook to h4 will be
checkmate
so g4 was mommy our last attempt to try
and survive this game but after 28 and
this is move 64 he decided to resign the
game as there is no defense either Queen
to h5 will be checkmate or Queen to e2
will be checkmate you can't prevent both
threats so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and just so I don't
forget here are the results across the
boards Caruana has defeated Momiji are
of very nice win a win against the 2820
player and as you'll see this this wind
brings Caruana
even closer to the
number-one-rated chess player in the
world magnus carlsen Wesley lost the
team over job of nakamura drew his game
against Arcadian i dish and the same
Shanklin want a very nice game against
ralph marvelous so the united states win
against Azerbaijan with a result of two
and a half to one and a half a very
important win as with this win I believe
haven't checked results but I believe
the the United States are now in first
place but it will be a clash against
Poland at tomorrow so again a tough game
for for Caruana against young Duda so
there we have it these are the live
ratings so as you can see car one is now
twenty eight thirty point thirty four
and a half so less than five points that
the Magnus Carlsen and it would be very
interesting if he could catch up to him
before November so it would be well for
the first time Carlson is playing a
World Chess Championship match where
he's not only a much higher rated player
but actually a lower rated player but
you know doesn't really matter
ratings are ratings you know so yeah
like I said I do hope you enjoyed it and
I hope you're enjoying the coverage of
the Olympics so far I would like to
thank Stephen green James radevich Mario
and samosa Christian Christian Gonzalez
Gonzalez del Castillo although perhaps
it's even Christian I believe and
Alexandra apron for a conclusion to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I'll see you soon hopefully
with some more interesting games thank
you all and I'll see you soon